do we ever flip that question hmm which  is a donor that might have a background  that is a little bit complicated or  disturbing that we would prefer not to  be transparent about I would not advise  them to going that road you know part of  why we are so relationship based in our  fundraising is we want to know the donor  we don't want Yale to be used for a  purpose that is not philanthropic and so  the donors who have made these be gifts  to Yale they all have a 10 20 30 40 50  year relationship with Yale so we know  them and they know us and it is a good  match I don't think we want to be in a  position where you know Yale is going to  be used for you know selfish purposes  for publicity or something like that